Oh, Hello!
Welcome
to the Sense8 lab.
I'm glad that the universe conspired to realing
what was off-center.
The minute the desicion was made,
everything has been super-speedy,
incredibly high octane.
Everything had to go, go, go!
We're back!
You were funnier last season.
Our show
builds bridges,
empowers people.
We all bleed when we're cut.
We all have the same thoughts.
We all feel grief and love.
It's always been about that common humanity.
It's a show that is for everyone.
We are surrounded
by the best quality of human beings
that we could have.
It's been beautiful.
Every pizzeria joint,
every set location,
they were there by the dozens.
It was nuts!
I've never seen anything like that.
It's because of the show.
Brazil, ıt was really crazy,
but really passionate.
We also get to be a part of that.
To see them, listen to these stories,
and possibly use that energy
while filming.
All those people,
in every country,
they are our extended cluster.
It just feels like a big ball of love.
My goodness, what a journey.
I'm proud to be a part of this,
and happy that we can
give them an end
that will satisfy them.